there is some very very bad news for
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis his
approval is collapsing as the anti-woke
movement is in a free fall in the United
States so let's back it up I already
told you
that Auntie woke may be a very silly
approach to the 2024 presidential
campaign and we are seeing loss after
loss after loss for the anti-woke
movement in the last 10 days on the
program I told you a judge has blocked
the Florida ban on gender affirming care
for Trans youth says not going to stand
Tennessee's anti-drag bill has been
blocked gay marriage is as popular as
ever in the United States
Utah's book ban backfired and led to the
Bible being banned in some schools and
the Book of Mormon under consideration
for a ban and now we learn
that Ron desantis's approval rating has
collapsed as Newsweek reports Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has seen his
approval rating fall dramatically two
weeks after announcing his 2024
presidential bid
according to online polling company
civics's Dynamic approval rating graph
DeSantis currently has a net approval
rating of negative 19. that means 55
percent disapprove 36 approved that's
minus 19. the data shows DeSantis has a
major unfavorable rating from those 18
to 34. women African Americans and
importantly the Hispanic Latino
population of Florida
in comparison he was even he was 47-47
approval disapproval in early December
so 4747 means zero right
uh 5536 means minus 19.
uh this is potentially very bad for
DeSantis Not only would it be great
to see DeSantis humiliated in 2024 from
the perspective of the presidential race
and much of that is bigger than DeSantis
and it has to do with factors outside
his control
it would be delightful to see this
feeble attempt at becoming the
Republican nominee be so damaging to his
reputation into his political career
that it precludes him from a viable shot
in 2028 and what I mean by that is the
following if DeSantis becomes so
unpopular by virtue of the anti-woke
insanity battling Disney don't say gay
all of this different stuff
it may lead to a damaged DeSantis who
can't even plausibly justify a run in
2028. up until two weeks ago when
DeSantis announced in that abortive
Twitter spaces event there were people
saying he may be better off waiting for
2028 don't damage yourself now
don't put at risk 2028 just wait 2028
Trump will be out of the way then you
run he'll still be I think 48 at the
time
but it would just be great to see him
destroy his own chances by virtue of
this absurd anti-woke campaign I want to
talk generally about Florida Republicans
because it's not a new thing that
Florida Republicans thought I'm ready
for the spotlight Jeb Bush thought he
was ready for the spotlight in 2016. in
fact his early polling wasn't bad and he
kept kept tripping all over himself low
energy please clap all of that stuff
Marco Rubio another Florida elected
official who thought 2016. I this makes
sense I've got a shot
Marco Rubio who hears about Rubio
anymore occasionally but Rubio and Jeb
mean neither would have even a minor
chance if they were to run at this point
in time and I have to tell you not so
much Marco Rubio but by the standards of
Republicans Jeb was an okay Republican
which is probably why he got crushed in
the primaries in the same way that I've
been talking about Chris Christie as a
somewhat reasonable Republican and
certainly the guy that would be my
choice if I were to vote for a
republican uh this time around Jeb was a
mildly reasonable guy certainly
mild-mannered and it was not what the
Republican party was primed for in 2016.
so is DeSantis destroying his political
career maybe is DeSantis at risk of
destroying his own shot in 2028 too
early to say but it would truly be a
delight to see that happen we are going
to be hearing from you coming up on the
program this weekend a number of streams
I do want to let people know the live
streams are going to ramp up again
so many 2024 candidates are regularly
scheduling events now and we are going
to be covering a number of them so make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube make
sure you're subscribed on Twitch and all
of the other places and so many things
will be happening over the next few
months that it'll make your head spin
let's put it that way we'll take a very
quick break and the Friday show
continues right after this